[Musik]
diese reise lässt wie china neu
entdecken schief an young führt mich
zurück in ihre kindheit ins leben der
provinz und ins herz ihres großvaters
raubte ihm die jugend doch er hat noch
einen traum er will berühmt werden ohne
seine enkelin schiefern hätte ich opa
können nie kennengelernt
kiefern ist meine brücke zwischen ost
und west und zwischen heute und gestern
ich bin so wie ich bin weil ich in
deutschland aufgewachsen bin und in der
gewesen weil ich dieses spannungsfeld
immer auch mein ganzes leben durch
erlebt habe um china zu verstehen
erforscht sie ihre familiengeschichte
und großvaters jugend und tomaten
dieser film ist eine annäherung zwischen
enkelin und großvater zwischen gestern
und heute und zwischen china und
shanghai
das new york von asien hier steht china
seinen reichtum zu schaden
hier bin ich seit vier jahren zu hause
im schmelztiegel zwischen moderne und
tradition
in der wohl sichersten und saubersten
stadt ganz chinas
unsere reise beginnt an der schüler
roadbook ina noch fast so aussieht wie
damals als schiefern in der tiefen
provinz zur welt kam mit vier zog sie zu
ihren eltern nach deutschland und ging
dort zur schule wo 20 jahre ist das her
jetzt kommt sie zurück nach china china
hat sich komplett verändert genauso wie
ski fans leben und langsam bröckeln
sogar die klischees sagt sie das so dass
die meisten deutschen nur mit reis
hütchen und hundefleisch und dann
vielleicht noch eben die
menschenrechtsverletzung in verbindung
gebracht haben und damals war auch ganz
klar wenn man mich wenn ich leute straße
angesprochen haben dann war das da ich
mich inzwischen werde ich in münchen
fallen auf englisch angesprochen weil
sie denken ich bin jetzt irgendwie
beruflich in europa oder ich bin
touristen die hier viel geld ausgeben
möchte
ich habe skifahren als büro kollegin in
shanghai kennen gelernt wie ich
berichtet sie aus china
oft ist sie hin und hergerissen zwischen
allen widersprüchen in diesem verrückten
land aber auch zwischen den
widersprüchen von ost und west
lange nachgedacht ich werde das auch
auch gefragt inzwischen glaube ich dass
das also ich für mich spielt ihre frage
einfach nicht mehr so eine große rolle
schiffer nämlich mit auf eine reise zu
ihren wurzeln im hochgeschwindigkeitszug
waren wir von shanghai nach pink in den
südwesten chinas dorthin ski-fans
familie herkommt
früher dauerte die fahrt im nachtzug
einen tag und eine nacht heute bringt
uns chinas schnellster zug in gerade mal
sechs stunden
skifahren ist stolz auf die tüchtigkeit
und den erfolg der chinesin werden
gleichzeitig macht ihr die brutale macht
politik der regierung angst im
schnellzugstempo pflügt der fortschritt
das land um über 1000 kilometer
baustelle sie in den wenigen stunden an
uns vorbei und nicht zu übersehen das
mag unter den fortschritt schon fast
wieder erstickt neue hochhäuser neue
straßen neue einkaufszentren hier
entsteht dass china der zukunft bei
sonnenaufgang sehen selbst
industriestädter romantisch aus das gilt
auch für skifans heimatstadt pinggera
1,6 millionen menschen leben hier für
china schon fast ein dorf im zentrum
trifft alt auf neu
es ist ein tanz zwischen tradition und
veränderungen weiter draußen am
stadtrand ist pink noch so wie früher
kohlegruben reihen sich an
arbeitersiedlungen so hat die stadt vor
20 jahren ausgesehen als schiffern hier
in den kindergarten ging doch auch pink
will heute modern sein
große teile wurden neu gebaut chinas
fortschritt hat die hintersten ecken der
provinz erreicht
immer wieder ist skifahren in den
vergangenen jahren hierher gekommen um
die geschichte des landes und die
geschichte ihrer familie zu erforschen
noch hier zur schule gegangen bin ich
bin ja
in der fünften klasse ein halbes jahr
zur schule gegangen da musste man noch
mit dem nachtzug nach shanghai fahren
oder fliegen
es gab ja eigentlich nur alte rostige
autos auf den straßen so lange bus
fahren hinter sich her gezogen haben
damals gab sich mal mcdonald's ich
glaube das einzige westliche restaurant
das ist gar caves die genauen sonst gab
es ja nicht zu viel
könntest du dir heute vorstellen hier
wieder hier zurück kommen ums leben
also hier leben wahrscheinlich eher
nicht aber meine mutter zum beispiel
können sich wieder vorstellen nach der
rente herzukommen
das heißt solche städte wie jetzt hier
das haben die bieten den leuten heute
jungen leuten auch alle zukunft ich
glaube inzwischen schon also das tut
sich
also es gibt inzwischen ja auch ein
wirtschaftswachstum auf dem land und
viele die weggegangen sind so wie meine
tante oder ein anderer onkel viele aus
der generation kann machen inzwischen
wieder zurück um hier zu investieren
draußen verdient haben schiffern führt
uns weiter zurück in ihre vergangenheit
in diesem quartier verbrachte sie ihre
frühe kindheit während vier jahren lebte
sie bei ihren großeltern während ihre
eltern in deutschland studierten
hier hat sich kaum etwas verändert
ihr großvater lebt heute noch da ist
jemand da
hast du nicht abgeschlossen
das ist der der 83-jährige opap an er
hat längst auf seine lieblings enkelin
aus deutschland gewartet
er will uns als erstes in ein
nudelrestaurant einladen beginnt zu fuß
gleich um die ecke
[Musik]
annehmbar gewesen
haben sie auch schon deutsches essen
gehabt einmal einmal ich wollte einmal
deutschland ist ein schöner ort sauber
die leute sind alle so zivilisiert
du hast vor 14 jahren einmal durch woran
erinnerst du dich noch die autobahnen
die hitler gebaut hat sieht noch in
gutem zustand
diese antwort hätte ich jetzt nicht
erwartet doch es wird nicht das letzte
mal sein dass uns der großvater
überrascht schiffern bringt das gespräch
zurück auf ihre eigene familie
sie will wissen warum eigentlich jede
mutter in deutschland studierte sie war
sehr gut in chemie sie war die einzige
und all den studenten der ganzen provinz
mit voller punktzahl weiter
maturaprüfung sie hatte 100 punkte
hast du stolz als sie dann anfang 90
wirklich ins ausland klar war ich damals
stolz natürlich das war für die krönung
zum kaiser
was hast du eigentlich dazu dass mama
mit mir in deutschland geblieben ist
gleich mehrmals
wenn kinder ihre schule fertig haben
müssen sie hinaus in die gesellschaft
wie die vögel wenn die flügel sind und
wind unter die flügel bekommen muss man
sie fliegen lassen
sie sollen hinausfliegen in die weite
welt sie sollen frei sein und überall
hinfliegen wo sie wollen
[Applaus]
auch ski-fans großvater wäre gern
geflogen wie ein vogel als er jung war
doch maut saison stutzte ihm die flügel
seine freiheit holt er sich wie viele
chinesen jeden morgen beim tai chi
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gerne wäre der junge punk song musiker
geworden
stattdessen geriet zusammen mit seiner
ganzen generation unter die räder von
chinas geschichte sein leben wurde zu
einem ständigen schattenboxen gegen die
launen des kommunistischen
machtapparates
der junge journalist galt als
intellektueller und wurde bald zum
staatsfeind ganz china wurde erfasst vom
strudel der kulturrevolution schon
brillenträger und lehrer waren suspekt
land arbeit statt denkarbeit lautete
maus parole damals universitäten wurden
geschlossen
zeitungen durften nur noch schreiben was
der regierung genehm war großvater punks
freigeist passte da nicht ins system
seine artikel waren zu auf mutig die
strafe kostete ihn 20 jahre seines
lebens er wurde zu zwangsarbeit verband
auf den berg der 1000 drachen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
heute fahren die leute freiwillig haften
drachenberg ist eine touristenattraktion
wie schön dass jetzt hier ist wie ein
fächer wie ein v der sein rad schlägt
man kann es kaum fassen
hier haben ski-fans großvater und auch
ihr onkel die schlimmsten jahre ihres
lebens verbracht
zusammen mit tausenden anderer
intellektueller mussten sie in
landwirtschafts kommunen zwangsarbeit
leisten
es war ein ständiger kampf ums überleben
als wir hier auf muss war die zeit der
schlimmsten drei jahre
es war verdammt schwierig in vielen
orten die leute nichts zu essen und
hungerten zu toren
im arbeitslager musste ich schwere der
schuld ich hatte mal etwas so schwer es
auf meinen schultern der sich um viel
das war nicht weit weg von ihren
gefühlen und stürzte einen hang hinunter
und war bewusstlos
andere arbeiter fanden mich und trugen
schließlich auf einer bahre zurück
es war die zeit vom großen sprung nach
vorn maus größten irrtum
eigentlich wollte er die wirtschaft
ankurbeln stattdessen verhungerten über
20 millionen menschen die fans groß
eltern konnten ihre kinder kaum mehr
ernähren
der onkel war damals ein baby es gab
nichts zu essen
wir mussten sie mit mäusen und ratten
füttern wir haben ihnen schlangen und
strotzen die wir fingen
du kannst dir nicht vorstellen wie hart
das leben damals war auch ich habe mir
das vorzustellen
die gegend ist heute bekannt für die
idylle und die frische bergluft man
kommt hierher um die stille und die
natur zu genießen
die tragische vergangenheit wirkt wie
vertuscht es scheint als wäre großvater
der einzige der sich noch daran erinnert
es ist fast ironisch wo damals leute
verhungerten schmausen jetzt touristen
die spezialitäten der gegend
wo großvater einst mäuse und ratten für
seine kinder jagte wird heute der beste
räucherschinken von china hergestellt
in diesem haus haben verwandte von
schäfern gelebt es ist das letzte
lehmhaus das noch an die düstere zeit
erinnert doch auch das soll verschwinden
an maus verbrechen soll man sich nicht
erinnern
also natürlich finde ich das unglaublich
dass meine familie hier früher gewohnt
hat und also man kann er sagen dass
gehaust hat und eigentlich alle
einfachsten bedingungen man sich heute
kaum noch vorstellen können für mich ist
das für mich ist es sehr sehr bewegend
weil ich bin völlig anderen welt kurz
geworden und reichen europa so das war
für mich etwas ganz ganz besonderes hier
zurückzukommen
zu gerne würde ich wissen was sich im
kopf des alten mannes abspielt europa
hat gelernt die schlimmsten momente
seines lebens zu vergessen und zu
schweigen
sind ja sehr verschlossen was ihre
innersten gefühle an begeht anbetrifft
ja also ich würde das nicht ich würde
das nicht können es ist einfach es ist
für ihn nichts besonderes dass es wahr
sein leben und dieses leben war geprägt
von ihm
chinas staatsgründer mao zedong wer sich
gegen den wert kämpft noch heute alleine
immer noch wird er verehrt wie hier am
stadtrand von pink er hat zig millionen
menschen auf dem gewissen
trotzdem heißt es offiziell hat 70
prozent richtig und 30 prozent falsch
gemacht
großvater köln hat seinen eigenen weg
gefunden mit den irrungen und wirrungen
von china umzugehen
[Musik]
das lied das heißt nur ein traum dieser
war das teilweise jetzt neu komponierten
teilweise aber zusammengefügt was früher
geschrieben hat die modi
[Musik]
si
i wo
der anfang ist gut hier muss ich noch
etwas ändern die musik ist sein bester
freund glaube ich und er hat sich ja in
der zeit der kulturrevolution ich glaube
wir achten sagt ich muss es gewesen sein
das war zur zeit dieser schlimmsten
massen
versammlungen als man ihnen
vor die menge gezerrt und dann muss der
stand haben tragen und jeden tag mehr so
übelste
ja beschimpfungen und auch schläge über
sich ergehen lassen noch schmähungen
dass ich dieses diesen halt dieses alter
ego ausgedacht
herr sommer bambus genau und also jeden
morgen verwandelt er sich eigentlich in
diesem sommer muss der davon treiben
eines tages nach mit seiner musik ab um
zu wenden
bis hierhin muss ich nichts mehr ändern
der text passt auch der weg zur
berühmtheit ist noch weit für den herrn
sommer bambus doch heute hat er einen
großen auftritt im dorf wo anteil von
kiefern sie bewohnt erwarte man in
bereits hier ist der sommer bambus schon
jetzt ein star
nach einer kleinen stärkung ist er
bereit sein großer traum kann beginnen
[Musik]
von judith a
jetzt hab ich vergessen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie geht das ich mir im moment nicht
heute war es nicht gut wenn hals kratzt
etwas ich bin erkältet
das letzte mal was super da warst du
lange nicht dabei ein langer tag geht zu
ende
wir fahren zurück nach pink und herr
sommer bambus verwandelt sich langsam
wieder in opern die kohle stadt rüstet
sich den feierabendverkehr aus den
lungen
zu hause in seiner wohnung träumt weiter
von einem leben als er sommer bambus von
einem leben ohne kulturrevolution und
hungersnot und von einem leben voller
musik und poesie
sein größter traum wäre ein auftritt in
einer casting-show beim chinesischen
staatsfernsehen
ich wünsche ihm dass er das noch schafft
schäfern und ich sind zurück in der
zukunft zurück in shanghai weit weg sind
hier die geschichten des herrn sommer
bambus weit weg ist japan mit seinen
kohle schloten und dem drachenberg nach
der reise zur op kann auch ich mir ein
bisschen besser vorstellen wie sich
schiff ans leben zwischen zwei welten
anfühlen
es ist ein seiltanz den schiffern schon
ihr ganzes leben lang kennt als würde
man aus dem raumschiff ausgespuckt und
dann ist man hier für ein paar tage und
dann steigt man wieder ein anderes leben
und es wieder sofort weg
und irgendwie denke ich mir nicht nur
der drachenberg sondern auch shanghai
sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein v der das
rad schlägt
[Musik]